in this video we're going to do a couple
of examples that deal with parallel and
perpendicular lines
so you have parallel
you have perpendicular
perpendicular and of course you have
lines that are neither parallel nor
perpendicular and just as a bit of a
review if you've never seen this before
parallel lines they never intersect so
if let me draw some axes so if those are
my coordinate axes right there that's my
x-axis
that is my y-axis
if this is a line that i'm drawing in
magenta a parallel line might look
something like this
it's not the exact same line but they
have the exact same slope if this moves
a certain amount
if this change in y over change in x is
a certain amount this change in y over
change in x is the same amount and
that's why they never intersect
so they have the same
same
slope
parallel lines have the same slope
perpendicular lines depending on how you
want to view it they're kind of the
opposite
if this let's say that this is some line
a line that is perpendicular to that
will not only intersect the line
it won't only intersect the line it will
intersect it at a right angle at a 90
degree angle
at a 90 degree angle and i'm not going
to prove it for you here actually prove
it in the linear algebra playlist but a
perpendicular lines slope so let's say
that this one right here let's say that
yellow line has a slope of m
then this orange line that's
perpendicular to the yellow line is
going to have a slope of negative 1 over
m their slopes are going to be the
negative inverse of each other now given
this information let's look at a bunch
of lines and figure out if they're
parallel if they're perpendicular or if
they are neither and to do that we just
have to keep looking at the slopes
so let's see they say one line passes
through the points four negative three
and negative eight zero another
line passes through the points
negative 1 negative 1 and negative 2 6.
so let's figure out the slopes of each
of these lines so i'll first do this one
in pink
so this slope right here so line one so
i'll call it slope one slope one is
let's just say it is well let's take
this as the finishing point so negative
three
minus zero remember change in y
negative three minus zero
over
four
over four
minus negative eight
four minus negative eight so this is
equal to negative three
over this is the same thing as four plus
eight negative three over twelve which
is equal to negative
one-fourth divide the numerator
denominator by three that's this line
that's the first line now what about the
second line
the second line the slope for that
second line is
let's take
here negative 1
negative 1 minus 6
minus 6
over
negative 1
minus negative 2 minus negative 2
is equal to negative 1 minus 6 is
negative 7
over negative 1 minus negative 2 that's
the same thing as negative 1 plus 2 well
that's just 1. so the slope here is
negative 7. so here their slopes are
neither equal so they're not parallel
nor are they the negative inverse of
each other so this is neither this is
neither parallel nor
perpendicular
neither parallel nor perpendicular so
these two lines they intersect but
they're not going to intersect at a 90
degree angle
let's do a couple more of these
so i have here
once again
one line passing through these points
and then another line
another line passing through these
points so let's just look at their
slopes
so this one in green
what's the slope
the slope of the green one i'll call
that the first line we could say let's
see change in y so we could do negative
two
negative two minus fourteen
over i did negative two first so i'll do
one first over one
minus negative 3.
so negative 2 minus 14 is negative 16.
1 minus negative 3 the same thing as 1
plus 3 that's over 4. so this is
negative
4.
now what's the slope of that second line
right there
so we have the slope of that second line
let's say
5 minus so say 5 minus negative 3 5
minus negative 3 that's our change in y
over negative two
negative two minus zero
so this is equal to five minus negative
three that's the same thing as five plus
three that's eight
and then negative two minus 0 is
negative 2. so this is also equal to
negative 4. so these two lines are
parallel
these two lines are
parallel they have the exact same slope
and i encourage you to find the
equations of both of these lines and
graph both of these lines and verify for
yourself that they are indeed parallel
let's do this one
once again it's just an exercise in
finding slopes so this first line has
those points let's figure out its slope
the slope of this first line one line
passes through these points so see 3
minus negative 3 minus negative 3 that's
our change in y over three
minus negative six
so this is the same thing as three plus
three which is six
over three plus six which is nine so
this first line has a slope of two
thirds
what is the second line's slope so this
is the second line there that's the
other line passing through these points
so the other lines slope let's see we
could say negative eight
negative eight minus four
over
over 2
minus negative 6 minus negative 6. so
what does this equal to negative 8 minus
4 is negative 12
2 minus negative 6. that's the same
thing as 2 plus 6 all right the
negatives cancel out so it's negative 12
over 8 which is the same thing if we
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 4 that's negative 3 halves
notice notice these guys are the
negative inverse of each other if i take
negative one over two thirds that is
equal to negative one times
three halves which is equal to negative
three halves these guys are the negative
inverses of each other you swap the
numerator and denominator make them
negative and they become equal to each
other so these two lines are
perpendicular
perpendicular and i encourage you to
find the equations i already got the
slopes for you but find the equations of
both of these lines plot them
and verify for yourself that they are
perpendicular